una visita Express pero de Gran
importancia el Primer Ministro ucraniano
y la primera dama o Elena selenka se
encuentran en París para asistir a una
conferencia de apoyo a Ucrania 47 países
participarán según ha informado el
Eliseo con un solo objetivo en la agenda
ayuda internacional de emergencia Rusia
continúa atacando a la infraestructura
vital de toda Ucrania afectando el
acceso al agua la electricidad la
calefacción y los alimentos además de
dañar hospitales y centros de atención
médica por eso los líderes de países
occidentales tratarán de ponerse de
acuerdo sobre el apoyo para ayudar a la
gente de Ucrania a sobrevivir durante
este invierno la reconstrucción del país
también estará en el centro de las
discusiones por el momento se espera que
tenga un valor entre los 400 y los
700.000 millones de euros pero la guerra
continúa una reunión entre las
autoridades ucranianas y casi 500
empresas francesas también está prevista
para esta jornada entre tanto este lunes
durante una reunión del g7 el presidente
ucraniano también lanzó un llamado
tenemos que ser más activos en la
reconstrucción esto mostrará claramente
al mundo Las verdaderas capacidades del
sistema democrático
cualquier ayuda aprobada en la
conferencia será adicional a las ya
otorgadas a kiev militarmente el Reino
Unido ha proporcionado el equivalente a
2700 millones de euros a Ucrania
mientras que la Unión Europea ha
depositado
19.700 millones de euros y Estados
Unidos el mayor donante del mundo el
equivalente a 68 mil millones de dólares
Joe biden ya está considerando una
puerta adicional que sí se aprueba
llevaría la ayuda total de Estados
Unidos a más de 100 mil millones de
dólares